what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
[Music]
and you even believe it the stock that
we're at right now not appliqué just
observing no trying to figure trying to
find speed try to find the sweet spot
good luck move it's still going it's
still going the flick technique is the
most risky oh my god
[Music]
oh my god Kate Kate you gotta aim
towards the top happening I think you
got to look for the top a little bit
more I don't know I think Kent Kent
what's the rule on that you feel someone
stole it it's really it's really
teetering it's really teetering no Bree
okay we need some like each other's
weddings about the owners in the city
[Laughter]
while he's getting the flick ready he's
getting the flick ready he's winding it
up don't flick technique cover the foyer
done
I do Robby's on that's the next level
right now
I don't I don't even know oh okay
uh I got to go on a flight in like four
hours to fly out to uh fly back out to
Los Angeles the beginning video you saw
it was myself and David David cage also
known as uncaged games also Jai where
was their comic story and and he editor
caboose like we were we all got together
we all went out to LA for a meeting of
sorts but we were playing Jenga David's
like hey man you want to play Jing and
I'm like he's like dude you can't you
can't handle you can't handle me in
Ching I'm like oh yes I can
like yes I can I played I played Jenga
at PAX East one year with like with with
like markiplier and jacksepticeye and
all those guys and they are beastly when
it comes to Jenga and all that do
they'll beat the hell out of you at the
Ginga games like I'm pretty good at
Ginga so like let's do this and it was
fun it was pretty amazing actually it
was pretty awesome
anyway ah Red Hood yes okay so um we're
doing Red Hood Andy well number two Red
Hood and Arsenal reunited and it feels
so good I'm really excited right now so
ah this comes off the tales of Red Hood
facing off against Batman and again that
was a really really cool little skirmish
there because I kind of put into sharp
relief the fact that like it is Batman
and like Jason Todd is not Bruce Wayne
and so at the moment he's kind of
recovering from his injuries really kind
of you know regaining his berries again
and this is an important thing because
this is crushing for Jason that's kind
of the tough thing about it is when you
look at the character of Jason Todd me
right now he's literally trying to shoot
it like a bowling ball and seeing if he
can if he can hit the target when you're
Jason Todd and you basically died and
then you were resurrected to the Lazarus
pits and then you were trained to become
a prodigious fighter and then you
basically took Gotham City by storm like
you have this track record of being an
exceedingly dangerous person and then
when you can't even hold a gun steady
and fire the trigger and hit your target
it's crushing because it kind of feels
like he's failed and that's what we find
out he's actually here with Roy Harper
now the Roy Harper Jason Todd chemistry
is is one of the things that like like
fans love them oh my god Red Hood and
Arsenal do they love that whole
situation because that really comes out
of the new 52 so sidetrack for a second
back when DC rebooted that in in in 2011
what they gave us was Red Hood in the
outlaws and what we got with this was
essentially like Red Hood and Arsenal
teaming up and it was pretty cool within
the first like and somebody can correct
me if I'm wrong but in the first like
four to six issues
it was Jason Todd who came across
Starfire
Starfire nursed him back to health the
two of them kind of it seemed like they
were gonna have a romance but DC never
really did anything with it they
eventually went to go rescue Roy Harper
Arsenal and then brought him back and
then it was actually Roy Harper and in
quarry a Starfire who ended up touching
touching naughty bits and so when when
that whole thing happened who basically
got like the outlaws concept and the
chemistry between all three was
incredible oh it was amazing and and it
was it was so fun to see the way was
written and it was so cool to see how it
all unfolded but what DC did is they
switched up the character of Roy Harper
and they changed his addiction from
heroin to alcohol now a little bit of a
dull time here when it came to the
character Hawaii Harper back with when
you had dinner so Neil and Neil Adams
who were riding the Green Arrow stories
are really Green Lantern Green Arrow
this story snowbirds don't fly is what
moved the green arrow stories from being
kind of like your traditional Silver Age
comics to becoming like a lot darker and
so that actually set the story that said
this age for like Mike Grell with
longbow hunters the miniseries and then
eventually the ongoing series it was
pretty cool you know when you had like
Green Arrow under vertigo but wouldn't
it when it came to the character of Roy
the Snowbird story arc was the one where
you found out he was addicted to heroin
and that was insane now in this day and
age because DC is is under Warner
Brothers moving towards a more
family-friendly direction or has been
for a very long time
they obviously couldn't do that because
even for a comic book that's still
pretty extreme back in the 70s you could
get away with that
nowadays you really couldn't do that
anymore and so they switched it up to
alcoholism and that's been a thing ever
since convergence I mean well not really
since convergence convergence kind of
retcon that in the sense that that was
his new 52 addiction and then when you
had a convergence that basically brought
in alcoholism I'm pretty sure that's how
it went but the fact remains here that
one other thing that that really hits
home is like how the two relate to one
another because Roy Harper is really the
closest thing that Jason Todd ever had
to a friend and it's a pretty
significant moment because what he ends
up doing is basically making his way
into the not only the mainframe but like
his his quarter of the the vessel itself
and we're in it were basically met with
Starfire now Starfire showing up here is
more like a hologram projection but for
Jason Todd is something that he needs
because what he needs to do is get back
to his comfort zone what do you need to
do is get back to a safe space that the
spot where everything will be okay and
by and large when it came to Jason Todd
the new 52 reboot and the idea of him
serving you know working alongside
Arsenal and alongside Starfire was a way
to kind of tone his character down a
little bit to make him a little more
comedic and a lot less dark and say what
you want while some people loved it some
people hated it
was an interesting shift to have what
we're seeing now is him returning back
to the days of like under the Red Hood
but there is still a little bit of
comedy there now something else that
goes on here goes on here with Roy
Harper is Roy Harper's actually talking
with Killer Croc now this is a really
really cool transition that's been going
on with Killer Croc for quite some time
in the sense that it has been DC's way
of kind of reworking his character but
not outright Killer Croc is basically
the sponsor for for Roy Harper in his
alcoholism and for those you guys who
don't know what a sponsor is a sponsor
is a person that you basically go to you
talk to you and they kind of help you
cope with your wits it's like a
psychologist without a psychology degree
they help you deal with your addiction
that things that you struggle with while
also helping to ground you and keep you
tied into the real world and so when you
have Killer Croc talking to Roy Harper
like this it's a really interesting
point of his character like Wayman shift
is is really awesome like the way the
Waylon Jones has moved over the years is
really really awesome because it makes
it more dynamic but to see this kind of
softer side as is is really really
intriguing because what he does he
starts to ask where Harper like
difficult questions you know and really
starts to make these these kind of
difficult cases you know one of the
things he says here he asked Roy he says
what makes you think you're in a
position to help somebody else when your
life is kind of turning to crap around
you and croc doesn't ask that question
for the purpose of tearing him down he
asked him for that but really for the
purpose of kind of frauding applauding
and saying look your life is a litmus
test for how you can help other people
your experiences you can bring to the
table
pass those experiences on to others and
then help them improve their own lives
by driving them to look at things that
they wouldn't normally look at them
before and it's kind of crazy because
Roy Harper's been dealing with this this
whole alcohol situation for a long long
time and it really has changed the way
that he sees things and so what you end
up having is you know switching over to
Jason Todd you end up having him hunting
for Artemis and bizarre and this is
probably the saddest part of this story
and the reason why is because where you
had arsal and you had um and you and you
had Starfire that was only ever going to
be a limited thing I mean we knew that
as the reader because we knew that
eventually Starfire would go on to
become part of the Titans you would have
an arsenal who would in some form or
fashion rejoin Green Arrow and then you
would have you know red hood go back
into his own thinking Gotham City we
knew it was only a matter of time before
the three split up but when you had
Artemis and you had bizarro you kind of
saw this group of people who were just
sort of thrust together through
impossible standards and then in turn
their characters began to shift and grow
in like incredible ways Artemis was by
and large is kind of like a solo
character and then she has to learn and
understand what it means to team up with
someone like
Jason taught whose moral ambiguity or
whose moral compass is very ambiguous
you've got bizarro who's technically the
dumbest person in the DC Universe who
gets injected with kryptonite and
because he's the opposite of Superman it
basically cures him where it fixes him
temporarily and he becomes a smartest
person who ever lived and he's working
alongside them each one of these
characters grew off the experiences of
the other characters around them and so
with Jason Todd it was a pretty close
family but not only that when you when
you look at Jason and Jason looks at
losing Artemis and he looks at losing
bizarro lost somewhere you know beyond
the multiverse then he in turn looks at
like losing style at losing Starfire and
losing Roy Harper losing arsenal and
it's constantly one of these things
where it feels like all Jason Todd does
is lose things all he does is experience
loss everything he cares about gets
taken away from him but the cool thing
about Jason Todd this is why Jason Todd
fans love him so much the cool thing
about Jason's character is he keeps on
going like in this instance it'd be very
free very easy for him to just roll over
and just say you know what it's not
worth it like I'm tired of losing things
I'm tired of sacrificing things I'm
tired of having the things that I love
taken away from me I just don't want to
do it anymore throw his hands in the air
and quit instead once he's once he's in
in form was he's good enough to do it
he's right back to work practicing you
know working on his workout working on
his regimen getting himself back in good
health these are the important things
that go on now the other half of this is
kind of like the two of them teaming up
for a quick moment looking for like
Suzie Suh and looking for what seems to
be like this criminal syndicate that at
the very least you can give them access
to where they can kind of gain
information from but Suzie Suh yes hoody
su this is a weird situation because
technically speaking at the beginning of
the new 52 with Red Hood in the outlaws
she was essentially dead like she was a
person who led like this you know
small-time criminal element you know I
don't know if it had ties to the Yakuza
or not it was like a small-time criminal
element she was defeated a couple times
by Red Hood and at the second outing he
shot her in the head and so it was
believed that she was just dead like she
was gone and out of the picture
apparently not like she's essentially
just kind of here and she's in a
comatose state or aplia is believed to
have been in a comatose state and is
actually shutting down but it's kind of
cool because they reference that right
late like they talk about that they talk
about how she's still alive here and it
doesn't necessarily make a whole lot of
sense because they're kind of like look
you know catastrophic liver failure is
what's killing her but it's kind of
funny Jason Todd shot her in the head
and this is the one thing that takes her
down so they reference past events you
know and so we can just kind of assume
there's somewhere along the line when
she was you know after she was shot she
was taken in
in brought to this facility and she was
kind of in there ever since now of
course Suze Suze henchman basically show
up and you know fight ensues and there's
nothing really major that goes on here
you know nothing nothing too significant
here Susie wakes up in the middle of all
this you know and and it's just kind of
like hey if anybody's gonna crush my
siblings it's gonna be me for the two of
you get out of here you know and like I
don't want to see you guys again it's
like yeah let's let's go ahead and go
let's get while the getting's good but
it's kind of a funny moment this is sort
of a small little throwback is really
what this is it's a love letter to
people who loved Red Hood and Arsenal
teaming up in the beginning of the new
52 and it's a great way to kind of do a
send-off and the reason why is because
Roy Harper's leaving he's going to the
heroes in crisis center yeah and that's
one of the things that he kind of says
here is there's a there's a center out
there there's a place out there that
heroes can go to for those who need help
for those who struggle but it's kind of
cool because they sort of go back and
and start to relive these old memories
and and you know kind of talk about
these old experiences the two of them
had you know with regards to their two
teaming up and and the various
adventures over the years and and so on
and so forth but it is kind of a cool
moment because for people who loved the
chemistry between Roy Harper and Jason
Todd it's bittersweet they get to see
them reunited and they get kind of a
taste of what it would be like if we saw
Red Hood and Arsenal team up in in you
know DC rebirth but it's bitter because
they know it's not gonna happen
that basically Roy Harper is leaving
he's going off to is to this you know
rehab and no one really knows what's
gonna happen it's almost kind of saying
a farewell like a like a final goodbye
to to Arsenal's character we don't know
what's gonna happen we don't know how
long it'll be before he comes back and
that's really what's being said here is
he's going off to find some help which
is much needed for his character over
the years something that he's finally
doing but it's like we don't really know
what the impact is gonna be on him we
don't really know exactly how all this
is gonna unfold in this a great little
moment to kind of give us it give a tip
of the hat and say hey these guys had
some great adventures together and maybe
they'll have adventures together in the
future we don't really know but for
right now this story of Jason Todd and
the story of Arsenal as a team is over
and at some point along the line and may
return we just don't really know when
beautifully done and beautifully written
but with that being said guys we're
gonna bring this video to an end if you
are new here too comments explained make
sure you guys at the sub button to
become part of the Rob core if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]
you
[Music]